in a world of sales there's always cause
and effect meaning if you only sold one
sale in a month that's the effect what
is the cause today we're going to talk
about six reasons why you're not selling
more and it's very simple it's not going
to be that long of an episode point
number one in sales if you are not
working very very hard this is not a
nine-to-five gig if you're not working
very very hard you're probably not going
to make it in sales it's that simple
selling requires a lot of time to be put
into it a lot of times you'll see people
who get into sales and and they're
waiting and they went from having a job
and they're thinking about wanting to
sell real estate wanting to sell
something and they're become an
independent contractor on the way to
becoming an entrepreneur and they still
have the same work habits of a job
you're not going to make it in sales if
you're just working just enough and then
saying how come I'm not selling more one
the reason why you're not selling more
is your work ethic number two is
competency you may not know a lot about
the product you may need to sit down and
learn about the product you may need to
sit down and know that ins and outs of a
product you may need to sit down and
figure out all the FAQ that a product
for instance if you have if you're
selling mortgages hypothetically and you
have five types of loans that would go
through the last top 100 loans that the
bank did and I would see what are the
main loans they do you'll see ninety
five of the loan ninety five percent of
all the loans they did was five
different types of loans perfect go out
there and figure out exactly what the
knows you know what the qualifications
for each loan is what's the minimum was
the details what's this for these five
loans become very very competent about
this you may be selling an insurance
policy if it's insurance policy go and
study the top five products the company
sells and then from there become
competent in those five products where
you know the ins and outs and study the
FAQ of every single product that you
have but become competent to the part in
the product if you don't know about the
product and a client asks you a question
you may not have the answer to them what
happens is after a couple of times you
get spooked
then you're afraid of going another
appointment because you don't want to
get caught and not have any answer to it
number three is how to you don't know
how to sell for instance maybe you lack
the skill set of how to sell how to ask
the right question
to ask the right leading question how to
open it up how to build rapport how to
build a relationship how to finish the
meeting how to open up the meeting how
to you know leave the house how to
establish a relationship how to make you
may not know you may need how-to areas
or how to sell a certain product how to
differentiate how to precise up a
competitor how to sit down with somebody
who is a customer competitor and how to
you know make the comparisons how to
compare policies how to compare
properties
it's the how-to part and the how-to part
to need help with there's very easy ways
to get good in the how-to side
it's simply read books on sales go and
get a hold of any book that you can on
the sales side whether it's from Hopkins
Cardona Tracy you know there are so many
great content you can find on sales side
to learn how to become a better salesman
so we have one work ethic two competency
three is how to four four is your
identity let me know what I mean by
identity identity is you believe in in
yourself that your worth
the person doing business with you if
you don't think you're worth a ten
thousand dollar Commission check you're
probably not going to get that
commission check if you put too much on
that you're probably not going to be
with the clothes that sell because a
client will get a feeling that you don't
think you belong in the big leagues so
let's just you come across a person that
only focused on selling $300,000 of
properties and then they come across a
client it's a one and a half million
dollar property the client will
generally feel if this person's ever
sold a one and a half million dollar
home and they'll say oh I don't know if
he really knows what he's doing I don't
know if she really knows what they're
doing I don't know if they really
believe they can handle a sale this big
so it's purely on your identity set how
do you work in our identity side is
being around other people that earn more
than you being around other people that
are doing much better than you being
around other people that are way ahead
of you that make a $10,000 check seem
like a small check being around other
people who are their energy is higher
constantly working on your thinking your
mindset elevating your thinking taking
yourself to a whole different level
being in the right environment being on
the right conferences listen to the
right CDs watching the right YouTube
videos the right podcast to its
increasing your identity because every
time you listen to this on a daily basis
all of a sudden say man I can make five
grand sale
I can make a $10,000 I can make a 2050
thousand in a month I can make 100 that
why not mean why not meet that identity
is increasing so so far one work ethic
to competency 3 how to and for identity
now let's talk about five point number
five is people skills is you watching
people a lot of times I'm at the
restaurant or if I go to to to airport
I'll size everybody I'll watch people
I'll go to a restaurant I'll say baby
look at the way you know look what
they're thinking about look at what's
going on what do you think on their
mouth what do you think they're thinking
about
I'm studying people I'm sizing people up
I'm thinking what they're thinking about
because in when you're in a meeting and
you're sitting out with somebody selling
you need to know what this means you
need to know what this means you need to
know what this means you need to know
what they're doing when they're looking
at the time they can't wait for you to
leave the house you need to know what it
means when they're young and you need to
know what it means when they're looking
at the kid the entire time they're not
paying attention you need to know what
it means when they're watching TV you
need to you need to know how to ask the
right question to demand them paying
attention to you in a way that's not
disrespectful because who are you to
come to my house and tell me to turn off
the TV who are you to sit down with me
and tell me to stop checking my phone
who are you to do that there's certain
ways for you to have that conversation
with them but it's people skills so how
do you become better at people skills I
mean you got to read the book how to win
friends and influence people there's a
lot of good books out there for you to
read psycho-cybernetics on people skills
but generally go and look at and think
about the five people you know that are
very good with people and watch them
study them just literally watch them
when they're talking to somebody just
watch them watch what they do watch the
way they sit watch how they smile watch
how the person watch how they're
pleasant watch their tone pay attention
to them see what they're doing to get
the other person want to do business
with them and you'll eventually pick up
the good news with the people skills
it's a skill so it can be learned it's
not something that people are born with
it it's a skill that can be learned on
how to deal with people on last but not
least the last part is belief in the
product you got to believe in a product
I think it's very very important believe
in a product no matter what you're
selling for me when I got involved in
in financial industry I am a big big big
believer in the financial industry I'm a
big believer of what investments will do
for you I'm a big believer what
insurance will do for him a big believer
what annuities will do free I'm a big
bully I'm a big believer in my industry
I'm a big believer in becoming an
entrepreneur I'm a big believer in our
product I'm a big believer and anybody
that I do business with that I enjoy
doing business with for a very very long
time there's a guy by cars with and I
bought cars with over the years this guy
believes in the company he represents
he's and he believes Ford is what he
bleeds he bleeds Ford
there's guy I worked with when I talked
to him about cars who's my main guy
called and and he just delivers the cars
to me the last eight years I've been
buying cars but I don't go to the
dealership anymore
he believes cars when I talk to him it's
just cars he believes in it he believes
in making a difference with cars he
believes in telling me Pat you don't
need to buy this you need this what are
you looking for you thinking about
trucks considered this one he believes
in the product and I want to do business
with somebody that believes in the
product that they're selling and
generally belief in a product you know
some people will watch this and they'll
say well you know I believe in the space
I want to go sell you know what do you
call it the things that go into the
space what do you call a shuttles little
space shuttle I'm going to go sell space
shuttles okay great you know I believe
and you know XYZ so I want to go out and
sell that I don't think it's also that
part of saying because people are very
quick to say well this is why I'm not
doing good sales because I don't believe
in this product I disagree with that I
disagree with that because I think you
are not giving yourself a chance to get
engaged and immerse yourself in the
product to see the passion to heart
behind a product to learn the product
and the effects it has into people yes
it may happen where sometimes you don't
believe in a product but a lot of times
it's just a way to cop out on why you're
not selling more and typically the
reason why most people if you look at
any of these things that I just talked
about do you know what's the number one
reason why most people don't sell you
know what's a number one reason is point
number one it's worth getting so I'll go
through one more time point number one
work ethic
number two product competency 3 how to
everything how to sell for is identity 5
people skills 6 belief in the product
right those six down rank yourself in
which areas you need help with 0 to 10
and attack the areas that you're having
problems with find people who are good
in those areas read the books that are
good in those areas and you'll see your
sales skills typically go higher because
nowadays there's no reason why somebody
shouldn't be making a six-figure your
income selling if you get those 6 points
right when it comes down to selling and
if you haven't subscribed to the channel
please be sure to click on the bottom to
subscribe to the channel and thanks for
watching take care bye bye